let's bring in our friend Sarah Sanders
foxnews contributor former White House
press secretary good morning G Sarah
good morning thanks for having me on
earning your welcome so yesterday I
don't know if you watched it but we had
that Town Hall on Brett and Martha did
an excellent job interviewing the
president in the Lincoln Memorial and he
was talking about something that's on
all of our minds just the balancing act
you know many of us are scared that
we're going to get it
but many are also scared about losing
jobs and watching this economy crumble
listen to this well I think you can
satisfy both have you scared you're
going to stay back a little bit and
you're gonna watch it but there are
other people that are scared about being
locked in a room and losing their job
and not having any income and you know
for the first time these are workers
these are people that want to get back
and work and make a living and they're
afraid their job is not going to be
there and at a certain point if you keep
it going too long that's going to happen
so I understand that very well what's
your reaction I think the president's
exactly right that he has a difficult
job in finding that perfect balance
obviously we want to do everything we
can to protect American lives while at
the same time protecting American
livelihoods I think the president's
taken the right approach in allowing
States to have a lot of flexibility in
making decisions that are the best for
those states I think mayors being
empowered is also a good thing because
what works in Arkansas isn't necessarily
going to be what works in New Jersey I
think the federal government has taken
the right approach and providing
resources and that flexibility to allow
states to make those decisions as you
guys talked about there are a lot of
states that are making some steps today
to start that reopening process the
American people are the type of people
that want to work they want to go out
and do their part and a lot of people
have
kind of mental and emotional health tied
to working and they want to get back out
there and I think that if they're in a
place and their workplace can allow them
to safely return that's a good thing for
a lot of Americans those that are the
most vulnerable still have to take those
precautions still need to make sure that
they're maintaining social distancing
they're following those guidelines but
at the end of the day I think under this
president's leadership he will find a
way to bring America back and bring our
economy back because he's done it before
and I think he can certainly do it again
well you know Sarah everybody's excited
about reopening the country for business
but at the same time the the door may be
open but the question is when will the
people come in as the people at the
business try to figure out how to run
and operate at a safe distance and
things like that then there's gotta be
confidence in the public that when I
walk in that place I'm gonna be safe and
I think that but I don't know if that
happens today or if it takes a little
time I and again I think this is one of
the things that's so difficult about
this process it's unprecedented and
something none of us have been through
before I think a lot of businesses are
going that extra mile trying to reassure
their customers I think a lot of the
processes that they've put in place over
the last several weeks allowing curbside
pickup and delivery and things like that
that they haven't traditionally offered
have helped a lot and I think we're
gonna continue to see that and that may
be that becomes the new normal hopefully
at some point over the course of the
next several months we can get back to
where group gatherings or something that
we get to do again I know that everybody
including the people in our household
are ready to see friends and family on
the regular basis again so Sarah I don't
want to see think politics is playing a
role but it's hard for me to not see
what's happening in Michigan seeing the
outrage and the slow roll out and wonder
if the Democratic governor like the
Democratic governor of Maine and the
Democratic governor of California are
creating outrage because the citizens
are seeing the
eat faster pace with the rollout and I
just hope the Democratic governors
aren't going I'm in no rush to turn this
economy around for this president do you
fear that or am I am i overthinking it
look I think these governors are trying
to make the best decisions they can but
ultimately they have to remember that
they have an obligation to the people of
their state to allow them to provide for
their families and if everyone else and
they get to a place where they can
safely do that they have one obligation
to at some point allow that to take
place
I think we need to provide the support
the resources and again I think the
president has done exactly the right
thing in providing that flexibility
providing financial resources for states
and in terms of supplies so that they
can do that and if yes to continue to do
that and hopefully the governor's will
make the right decision to do what's
best for the people in their communities
both protecting their health and
protecting their economies because at
the end of the day those people are
going to be voted for as well they'll
either get to keep their jobs or not
because they did the right thing by the
people in those communities that's right
so Sara we've all had to find ways to
talk to our children about this
depending on their age we give them
specifics my daughter's 4 so she doesn't
really understand this but I know you
how old are your kids I have an 8 year
old a six year old and a four year old
okay so the president was asked about it
how he's telling his son how he's
talking to his son about it and and his
grandkids listen to this I sat down with
my son I sat down with my grandchildren
I said a terrible thing that's happened
it's a thing that we've never
experienced but I said something's
happened but we're going to be strong
and we're gonna get out of it and our
country is going to be bigger and better
and stronger than ever before how did
you talk to your children Sara much in
the same way you know I think the most
important thing we can do is be honest
with our kids and be transparent my kids
are young so it's hard for them to
process everything that's going on they
don't understand why they can't go to
school and why they can't play with
their friend
every day but at the same time we've
tried to really focus on some of the
positive things that we still live in
the greatest country on the face of the
planet we have a God who loves us and
ultimately this is all under his control
and we've got to spend a lot of time
together as a family we've been
homeschooling our kids that could be to
their detriment but it's been a learning
experience for all of us but at the end
of the day we've tried to be honest with
our kids it can be very difficult to
hear your four-year-old pray every night
that he hopes nobody gets killed in his
family from the virus but at the same
time we try to reinforce that again we
have a God that loves us and that we are
still in America in the most resilient
and tough country and we will come back
and we will come back stronger and we're
gonna do that together as a family and
as a country that's right we're in this
together sir what do you make of the
fact that over the last week or so the
president has stopped doing the nightly
five o'clock or 6 o'clock p.m. press
briefings where it might go half hour
might go two hours and instead does more
targeted events during the day like that
small business day it's first responders
day where he has guests into the White
House and then you had the big event
last night at the Lincoln Memorial is
that effective more effective and
getting the message out I saw that over
the last two weeks I think it was Gallup
says that the president's ratings now
have gone up six points in two weeks
look I always think it's a great thing
for the president to speak directly to
the American people he does that in a
variety of different ways some some days
it's by Twitter some days it's by Town
Hall at the Lincoln Memorial and some
days it's in the press briefing room I
think the important thing is that the
president has been accessible and he has
been very upfront and vote
and shown that he's an actual leader in
this country's time of crisis he stepped
up at a time when we needed him most and
he's been up front and center and I
think that's been really important and
when he needs other people to come in
whether it's the vice president Larry
Kudlow
dr. Fauci and dr. Burks and others to
come forward and talk about a different
message he's done that I think he's done
the right thing in providing constant
and frequent information I love the
different formats and venues I think he
should continue to do that and I also
think Kaylee mackaninee did a phenomenal
job last week in her first press
briefing I think it's a good idea to mix
that up and have her continue to engage
and speak on his behalf as well so Sarah
the New York Times had a brilliant idea
they thought it would be a great idea
for the DNC to investigate Joe Biden
about that sexual assault what could
possibly go wrong let's really get to
the bottom of it because you know
they're gonna drill down deep until they
get that answer so everybody was saying
are you kidding me I think I'm going to
I'm going to reject my subscription
again so also add to this on the
allegation from Tara Reid Fox News has
learned that Ronan Farrow is doing the
extensive piece in The New Yorker on
this listen the last thing this country
needs is any another another sex scandal
to go through it but it's not our choice
where do you think this is heading look
when you first said the New York Times
had a good idea I knew something must be
wrong the idea that the DNC would be the
one to take the lead on any
investigation involving one of their own
candidates is laughable I thought it was
an onion headline not in New York Times
headline they should be embarrassed for
themselves for even suggesting that idea
at the end of the day I think people
just want fairness the hypocrisy that
we've seen from the left is truly
mind-blowing the fact that they went so
aggressively after justice Cavanaugh and
demanded to get to the bottom of things
but want to just brush this aside I
think is the real challenge that most
people are dealing with
now and they want to see a level of
fairness from both sides and the
hypocrisy from the media and the left on
this is is really hard to swallow I
think that we should move forward put
the information out there let the
investigation go where it may and again
maybe joke comes out great and good for
him if he does but at the end of the day
we have to go through the process of the
investigation and see what happens and
it should be fair on both sides okay
Sara thank you for joining us great
thank you so much you're welcome